[Music]
oh my god guys i have the funniest
freaking story from china
china
no no china a restaurant
in china they were asking their
customers
to stand on scales and get weighed
so then they can like be scanned like
their data gets scanned into an
app and then i'll recommend food choices
based on their weight
oh so it's like a it's like a fitness
store hey you fat ass you need more bok
choy in your life
no it's probably like hey fat ass you
probably want fried food huh
i know i know that's [ __ ] funny they
customize it to your weight
i know in china weight is like a huge
huge [ __ ] thing like the way you look
and stuff because we did an article here
too where uh one of the restaurants had
bars
and then it oh yeah pass through it and
if you weren't then you were too fat so
they wouldn't
and also the level of pc in china is
different from here
so like things that actually means
whatever like yeah you can't be like
the things that you're shameful about or
it's inappropriate they're just straight
up
it's a fact yeah you fat yeah well not
really because they
did get a lot of flack for it you know
why because there's a chinese sjws now
oh are they good really would you call
them chinese sjws oh
so justice worry are they getting flat
from here or flat from over there
i don't know from where but i know that
there is backlash
on social media social media backlash
and in china and so they were saying
that they were apologizing and that
the intention wasn't to fetch that shame
it's just that recently the president
has urged people to not toss out excess
food since there has been a food
shortage
of some products due to the pandemic and
also
flooding and so for that reason that's
why the restaurant was like oh you know
we were just trying to make sure that it
says
our original intentions were to advocate
stopping waste and ordering food in a
healthy way we never forced customers to
weigh themselves
they could have just [ __ ] charged for
the leftovers
i mean that's another way to do it but
they don't want to waste food at all so
they're like hey you're a fat as you're
going to finish your plate so i suggest
you to order
the king-sized that's probably what
they're thinking
i don't know exactly how it worked out
but they were saying also that
they like that china is looking into
limiting
because you know how the way that they
order in china is like family style so
they'll order like based on how many
people are in the group
and so they're saying that to change the
methods to order
for one less person oh so instead of
ordering for a group of eight order for
a group of seven
even though you have eight people that
way you for sure finish the food wait
that's kind of genius
if i'm thinking about it the right way
where it's like your party
is let's say 200 pounds collectively
right
and humans at that weight will need this
many calories
so they're like calculating how much
food that would be [ __ ] genius that
would be smart your party is 200 pounds
collectively
these are very small people if it was
children i don't know if that's a good
metric
i didn't even think about that could
have been three two three [ __ ] kids
i just knew it wasn't going to be
accurate so i was just like he's
throwing numbers yeah that's why i
thought i left when i realized like oh
[ __ ] the numbers
like i guess i guess those metrics don't
really make sense to me because
um i've seen really petite people
[ __ ] scarf the [ __ ] down
and i'm not very petite but i'm using
stupid people logic dude hot dog guy
who's the hot dog guy he's skinny oh
yeah
kobayashi you have 50 hot dogs in a
minute or some [ __ ] yeah that guy's
skinny as [ __ ] but like me
i'm like bigger and i would weigh more
than an average chick
i don't eat as much doesn't phelps burn
like
ten thousand calories or some [ __ ] a day
right what what burns
michael phelps like these olympians and
that's ten thousand yeah they'll eat
that much oh they're lost yeah so then
the calculations are
stupid yeah i don't know if the chinese
eating culture is different but
growing up uh both my parents told me
when you go out to eat with your family
you purposely
order more so that you can have
leftovers to take home
so you purpose if you have like four
people you purposely order for
a group of five or six so you can take
the extra food home and now you have
food for the next
two or three days too or like in my case
you take it home
and then you can just leave it in the
fridge for seven weeks you don't need
your leftovers
not really me neither yeah my shirt
feeds all of them i always feel very bad
me too cause i'm like i had the
intention to not waste this but then as
i'm throwing it in the trash after three
months of it sitting there i'm like
have you ever left it there and you see
the white tray in there for after a very
long time and you don't even open it you
just take it out
yeah you're scared to look inside
i don't have food waste anymore really
how how come
i cook everything and then if i have
food i just figure out ways to repurpose
it did you have a chef for a while
yeah but he's busy now because we opened
up
seven days a week go and if you're in
the la area get some shrimp daddy we're
open from 11 to 4 p.m now it's available
on doordash
and many many other places like grubhub
and ubereats and all that
but yeah we're all investors in it time
yeah exactly is so he's working there
now yeah he's busy there
so i i don't i don't know and i'm now
i'm eating
way less i'm doing a combination of
intermittent fasting
and [ __ ] i'm doing like juice
cleansing and [ __ ] like that
and like only like one meal so like one
meal a day right now
one big one like on the couple days i'll
you know i don't do that every day it's
gonna give me [ __ ] hypoglycemia you
know
but uh when i do do those days though it
[ __ ] me up
i don't know it messes with your mind
the one meal days
yeah yeah they say it takes like a week
or two to get used to it right
so if you just wait that's the thing
that's a diet that's a fat some people
some people fast
alternatively like they'll they'll not
eat one day they'll just drink water and
then the next day
they'll eat didn't joe rogan say does
that he like intermittent fasting than
eat one meal well the intermittent
fasting is you eat at a
hour window a couple hour window per day
but
just some people do water fast or
whatever where they just don't eat that
whole day
oh wow it's nuts that's like the
what the jews do with fasting i'm always
like how the [ __ ] can you fast
with the ramadan i think they both fast
right oh i don't know
muslims are longer i think right but
it's inter manifesting with muslims like
during ramadan they eat after sunset
or there's like an x amount of hours but
then they don't eat during the daytime
they can't even drink water during that
time no water
they can just rinse their mouth out yeah
i think that's it i get a crazy headache
if i don't eat for like 10 hours or
something
i can't imagine i can't fast at all no i
can't then after you get over that
period
it's crazy what it does you start you
you get an it's it's almost like uh you
know when you pull an all-nighter
and you feel really tired and you you
feel like you can't take it anymore you
get that second rush of energy
it's that starts happening where
you feel so hungry and tired and then
like this new
energy kicks in happens to me all the
time because i always just have like
one or two meals a day but i get what
you're saying about the energy thing
because i'm like
there's a like there's a hump that i get
over where i'm like [ __ ] i've been
hungry for so many hours i don't know
why i don't feed myself i just don't
and then next thing i know like that
hunger is gone but then i i'm just like
really like
go you're just super delirious i guess
you're hallucinating and you're like wow
this is great
i'm actually not that bad anymore i do
eat normally
now but you also drink water
consistently throughout the day too
a lot there's hella different diets
though but i think like from all the
research all it is
i think the basic concept behind
everything
that seems to be working is you consume
less calories than you burn
or you burn more calories or what it was
burn more calories than you less
yes yes i said switching words around no
you burn more calories and then you eat
less yeah
yeah so you're you're constantly at a
deficit if you want to get leaner yeah
yeah
so if you want to lose weight it's all
you just constantly at a deficit but i'm
trying to do a lot of different things
like uh not only lose weight but like
just eat cleaner and healthier and
things like that so i don't get skin
conditions and [ __ ] like that
so yeah isn't it wild that with this
stuff like
excess food wise that you can't um
give away food like to like say homeless
people because of code and [ __ ]
you get sued too sometimes i suit if
someone gets sick yeah it's wild man
yeah i just read that recently and i was
like man that is crazy some companies
want to like especially like
on set you know the catering companies
that are they're like 24 hour on call
because sometimes you should have night
shoots day shoots
and then there will be entire untouched
pies or untouched
tri-tip because they're just they made
too much food
they still have to just throw it away
they can't give it to the homeless
people because of cold
or they're scared they're going to get
sued so yes food waste is just part of
the industry restaurants grocery stores
they all do it
i was watching how this one minimalist
dude he
basically dumpster dives and it's the
craziest thing because he just goes to
like these different grocery stores or
whatever
and then he finds just cartons of eggs
and just
regular things that they're still good
i mean that's like [ __ ] joe exotic
you know he used to grab all those
walmart meats
oh yeah tigers yeah
true yeah and also just like with
produce um if it doesn't look really
pretty then they're like
toss it but the produce is completely
fine but when you buy it though i'm like
i'm like
no i'm not buying that one right because
we've been conditioned to see it that
way and i know during the pandemic and
stuff there was
um some places that had food shortages
so there were some communities within
the us
it could be like in new york and stuff
um that they would have like a community
refrigerator and they would just have it
outdoor
i've seen some of those yeah people
would take something and then leave
something i thought that was really cool
because who's really gonna get sued
because it's just
the whole community doing it it just so
happens to be there
yeah so i thought that was dope that
yeah because that's something that we
always think about too
with all of our other food concepts is
like being in the restaurant industry
you realize how much waste goes down
so you try to figure out ways to purpose
everything
and not only is it cost effect effective
you you make more money that way too if
you if you know how to like
use everything that's like chinese
people are killing it yeah they use
everything they use
everything i mean isn't that the idea
behind a lot of restaurants having like
the special of the day when they have
the extra menu it's like they're using
the leftover ingredients to make those
specials
oh [ __ ] is that why yeah you didn't know
[ __ ] no i didn't know that yeah
you're not supposed to like get order
fish right i forgot what it was
yeah there's a whole book oh it's
because of um bourdain anthony bourdain
he had this book
back in the 90s the one that blew up
that yeah the one that blew him up and
then
that was some of like the restaurant
secret that he was exposing don't
order fish on the side what are those
specials that are not printed in the
menu
but now like way years later like years
years
later like because people kept asking
him about that one particular thing
about don't order fish and whatever
he was like i've been to so many places
all over the world
there's so many restaurants that have
really high quality fish so i wouldn't
use that as a blanket statement i see
yeah
maybe it was true in the u.s locally
yeah
in new york yeah because it's like i
wouldn't use that rule in
l.a or somewhere you have access to
seafood or whatever yeah
if if it's a restaurant near the harbor
yeah i wouldn't worry about it that's so
[Music]
true
[Music]
you